I'm going to begin by setting a couple
of questions for our panel and then wait
wait we're gonna start with a little
conversation across the table and then
we will extend out I'd like to ask I'd
like to ask our panelists to first
address one of these critical
comparative questions that you just
closed with in fact without having to do
with the relationship in the two
constitutional and and and also
political traditions between the
insistence on individual equality on the
one side and the concern about dealing
with the impediments to that equality
that have been built into social
cultural and economic kinds of
conditions of life material conditions
but material conditions that extend in
fact to of course religious life
especially in the Indian context and I'd
like to add to that the question that
comes out of the way Lee posed the
defense and his choices in relationship
to the defense over the two cases
against the University of Michigan
namely his insistence on linking the
question of diversity which is to say
diversity as a value for everyone in the
room or in the university or the
classroom or the or whatever the context
might be and the ways in which diversity
is needed because of its work of the
because of the work it needs to do to
address historical oppression historical
discrimination indeed again to repeat
what I said before the historical
conditions that have led to the problems
that that have to do with what it means
to bring diverse groups together
under certain kinds of equal conditions
so just to kind of clarify to at the
outset the the way these these these
legal traditions as it were
have evolved in relationship in some
ways to a very similar history which is
to say a history of slavery on the one
side which then continues in all sorts
of ways after formal emancipation in the
United States and the history of caste
discrimination which is as you made
clear and as I think we all agree
clearest and and most demonstrable a
kind of universal condition with respect
to the most oppressed and the most
marginalized groups in India leaving
aside for a second the kind of openness
of these of some of these groups and
categories in the in the history of
scheduling but obviously refrain here
specifically to scheduled castes and
tribes so I'd like to then move later in
a subsequent exchange to the question of
what the what the broader categories
will entail when you start thinking
about other backward castes in India or
possibly categories in the United States
having to do with populations that could
I'd be identified of color or you know
the whole set of questions that that
that have to do with whether or not
you're on some schedule of
underrepresented minorities but I'd like
to bracket that out for the initial
question and so Italy I'd like to ask
you perhaps first just to reflect a
little bit about the American tradition
in relationship now to what you've heard
from both mark and and forethought and
and just try to clarify the divergence
which is that is very very stimulating
because I think it's it's resonating
with things that that I have thought
about in the American context in many
ways I think in some ways what we're
trying to get inside of the broad social
dynamics of affirmative action when it
is linked well affirmative action we
know what it is and how it
it sort of helps achieve a broad social
goal or how it actually inhibits or
impairs achieving that goal and does
that the things good but could I just
ask you to know for you Nick to say
again it was when you said you wanted to
bracket something and I just I think I
was thinking about something else and I
want to ask I want to answer no no I
just wanted to bracket out the question
of who is denominated by affirmative
action in the Indian and the u.s. cases
whether it be extended beyond the
specific populations of Scheduled Castes
and tribes on the Indian side and
whether some of the issues arise
affirmative action in the United States
be extended to populations beyond the
african-american community I want to
wait on that okay because that was
something yeah it will obviously come
when we start talking about the the post
54 history of reservations in India for
the moment I want to just go to these
questions around what pratap called the
ethical requirements of of affirmative
action in relationship to the divergent
discourse as i as i hear it between
diversity as a value for all and
diversity as a form of redress for
historical exclusions and
discriminations and oppressions in the
past and you made clear in your defense
of the university of michigan you needed
to link both but you were also to some
extent constrained by as i understand it
anyway the 1978 articulation of
diversity is a particular kind of value
of greater importance for the supreme
court at least at that point in its
decision than the historical issue so so
let me just try recognizing that that I
may be missing the point but
I think I think inside of the social
policy and practice of affirmative
action is a set of inner tensions that
that that really have to be revealed so
when I think about the first period in
American history with this enormous
effort to reshape American life using
race as as a prototype of what needed to
be addressed and then seeing other
things from that often in the context of
race racial divisions that needed to be
figured an enormous social
transformation process that's underway
affirmative action coming out of that as
one tool to achieve this and the
argument about linking it with history
of injustice is very much motivated by
this must change and it must change not
only in ending discrimination we must
integrate in a broader narrative to use
projects term but then there is a period
in which people say you know it's not a
good thing to link everything to history
and make people victims and and have
them live and why and why does this
group deserve to be the victims they're
there they've had time since the
discrimination and on the other hand
it's really good to have lots of things
we don't want people to this generation
to feel as if they're somehow
distinctive when in fact we've been
practicing affirmative action for four
centuries Geographic affirmative action
is one of the most prominent that's just
not put into these debates very often
it's
so for decades universities would take
people like me from Oregon because they
didn't have any people from organs in
New York City so so I was the
beneficiary that's that's right I was
the beneficiary of affirmative action
and the and you wanted to get people
from different parts of the country and
you took that into account and maybe
their SAT scores or L SATs weren't as
high and and and that's the same thing
with race so why are we singling these
people out and making them an exception
and somehow the the the victims who need
to be helped us that's normalized this
and it's also good for them to be
normalized and then that becomes
disconnected from the history it becomes
kind of crazy because you you say and
then the point is I like the the point
the issue of emancipation on the cheap
that's a very powerful argument and
often made in the context of the
affirmative action cases we've made very
strongly to me by many people who were
opposed to to what we were advocating
they would say you are doing more to
harm race relations in America then
you're doing anything close to helping
because the real problems are in K
through 12 by the time the students get
to you they're already formed and and
you now give the society an excuse for
not doing anything about this and and my
view was always I agree with you we're
just doing the best we can you know
you're gonna stop doing a little bit
because you can't do the society won't
do a lot and and that kind of inner
tension I think revealing these inner
tensions to me is is very important
that's what
yeah this question of diversity is
interesting because it seemed to me on
both in both India and the u.s. the
driving impulse is to rectify a
historical wrong
and in some sense and particularly in
the American case diversity is window
dressing it's because there were people
who were reluctant to buy this notion
that we got a depart from equality for
this reparative purpose they say ah but
diversity that's the kind of prospective
forward-looking we really want a society
in which the officer corps looks like
the troops so it's okay to have
diversity because it'll produce that
kind of social lubrication as a result
but in fact you know so we we get this
diversity and of course diversity and
one other feature of the American system
has to be put in in contrast with the
Indian system we who can be a
beneficiary of this where we just use
kind of intuition and self declaration
as opposed to the Indian system where we
have a measured official determination
of the eligibility of groups and we have
basically these publicly assigned
identities of eligibility which in some
sense creates or aggravates the problem
as we defined it this notion of
compulsory identities but so in the
American system its immunity we end up
with you know recent immigrants from
Africa oh that's fine because that's
diversity and in some sense Sandra Day
O'Connor comes forth with this totally
incoherent things she says yes it's
diversity diversities great we're not
doing this for operations it's all for
diversity but it'll go away in 25 years
because basically the blacks will be
will be integrated and what about other
forms of diversity what about you know
in 25 years surely it's gonna be some
other the kind of diversity that will
look attractive for policy purposes so
so in the u.s. as I say diversity is
kind of window dressing but very
influential window dressing in India on
the other hand it seemed to be the the
the rationale of reparation was very
much there but what we when the OB sees
the other Backward Classes get added in
and off in the wings are the Muslims too
as a possible add-in of another
beneficiary group what we really get is
diversity we get or it in the sense of
communal quotas that as everybody gets
their proportional share this was it
seemed to me on bed cards fear and the
fear of many people in the in the
Constituent Assembly and they said we
don't we don't want a regime of communal
quotas we want a regime of open movement
and open competition but we are making a
an exception or a temporary exception we
hope for the Scheduled Castes I'm
assured your tribes
in terms of basically giving them this
additional protection to make sure they
they are brought into into into the
mainstream so but what happens is with
the addition of the arrival of the OB
sees and basically their the the
domination of the of the compensatory
discrimination program by the OB sees
what we end up with is in effect a
distributive politics that is it's
easily translatable into diversity
everybody gets their share and everybody
has to be present and so so in curious
way the Indian program which is which is
rationalized as reparations ends up
being a diversity program and the
American program which is which is is a
kind of hidden and very partial
reparations program because it has to be
labeled and administered as diversity I
mean what I think you know one of the
things we've learnt I think from the
literature and affirmative action in
both context is that I think the
abstract discussion about the
relationship between individual liberty
inequality
I think the philosophical concepts get
you only so far in coming to grips with
in a sense the phenomenology of the way
in which actually identities are formed
I mean and and so so that it may not be
so much of a matter of sort of normative
resolution which is in a sense easy I
mean there's a sort of fairly
straightforward structure it is
individual pace there are some
individuals on this disadvantage because
of their historical circumstances by
virtue of the identity that they possess
if you give them the opportunities bike
or some compensatory way they will be in
a position to take those I mean that's
the kind of the simplest
I think what makes the story complicated
I think particularly when and you've
written so powerfully about it which is
one is the idea of identities being
constructed through innocent state
legislation or around the axis of what
it is that the state distributes I mean
I mean that that that itself is a sort
of is no very it's it's a strange
conception of both identity and liberty
if you like the second thing and I think
there the contrast with the United
States is is is is is interesting which
is that I think the institutional
context matters a lot so in the United
States you were looking at an
institutional context of higher
education where institutions have vast
discretion in tailoring all kinds of
policies their admission I mean that
there are free institutions I mean you
know Columbia comes up with its own
criteria and so forth the difficulty
with the Indian model was that the
diversity did not extend to any form of
diversity of experiments about what
kinds of institutional forms good
experiments with diversity take I mean
you know and so the United States really
the constitutional question is one of
permissibility of certain diversity
programs in India that's a
constitutionally self question I mean
you know that's that's allowed but
paradoxically that constitutional
allowance was set in an institutional
context where the state was extremely
rigid about what particular
configurations institution squad could
actually take which is why some of our
debate about merit and so forth gets
skewed I mean you could have easily
imagined I mean a university system in
India which is more like California a
bunch of colleges will say we will admit
whoever comes it really doesn't matter
you know what you're grading what we
will hang our religions to is the fact
that in two years we will equip you to
progress on to a next level of history
now those kinds of experiments are not
allowed right so in a sense it is that
single point that has to bear the weight
of all these identity
concerns and in a sense you dramatizes
the politics actually and the final
thing about diversities is that in a
sense the consequence of the state
constructing identities in this way is
that what identities are salient it
becomes a sort of circular argument I
mean I think I mean I think everybody
agreed that Dalits were a special case I
think in its but but which identities
you choose to privilege what kinds of
diversity is mattered for what purposes
that diversity matters I think that has
become entirely self fulfilling okay I
think given the time we should open up a
little bit to some questions and
comments please make your your questions
brief so we'll have a chance to yeah
could you please identify yourself when
you when you speak David thank you David
shazar from the law school here at
Columbia it's been very interesting to
see the comparison between the United
States and India I wanted to propose
very quickly another comparison which is
South Africa in India because the South
African Constitution has language which
at least was intended to guarantee
minimum economic rights to people in the
country and it's proved to be somewhat
difficult for judges to administer
although there's there certainly an
effort we were lucky to have sandelion
Cobo which just named the chief justice
of the constitution here a number of
times to teach for us he's very
interesting on the subject so I suppose
particularly for professor Mehta you
said if the reservation system is sort
of on the cheap would you be attracted
to something more like that normatively
if you were would you want it to be
administered by courts or more by the
legislature no I mean I think the South
African example is in a sense very
interesting right and and and I think
the later the Constitution is formed in
a sense the more the state is empowered
to do certain kinds of things I mean it
is an interesting question whether the
formal promulgation of constitutional
rights is a good predictor of how in
fact those rights will be realized I
mean and I think on education Crees
primary education arguably the normative
consensus has turned enough in the
ten years even though the right to
education has now been promulgated by
the Indian Supreme Court legislation has
been passed that you will sort of get
you know you'll begin to get more
movement towards in the in that
direction and courts may actually have a
role to play a role to play in that but
but I don't think we should
underestimate the fact that there needs
to be a honest conversation about all
the complex elements that need to be put
in place for those rights to be
effective once I mean it's a banal point
but but but it actually doesn't fit
thank you and why you law school I think
two points in terms that connect India
and the United States that that haven't
really been addressed but I think go to
why the conversation is taking the turn
is taking in both countries have to do
with one the historical the use of the
even the term historical and justices
Rob's the discrimination in both
countries of it's very contemporary
characters so I'll speak to India in
particular the situation of Dalits in
India today as many of you know is not
one of surviving or coming out of a
historic oppression condition it is very
much contemporary and it's seen in the
daily atrocities in the segregation and
just in the vast poverty violence and
discrimination that's meted out against
a majority of belet's in the country
today a very small percentage are
actually reached by the reservations
program but the Indian government has
also included within that ambit a number
of socio-economic development measures
that too have been completely under
enforced or sabotage by a siphoning of
funds from those programs to other
activities so even where reservations or
I should say rather affirmative action
has been imagined more broadly it has
been under enforced or completely
undermined the second point is that the
language of that is being used to defeat
any sort of affirmative action across
both countries is very
I think and and is is creating resonance
and among the two continents the
language of meritocracy of liberalism of
equality of colorblindness and now
increasingly the language of caste
blindness serves I think to use equality
as a weapon against affirmative action
in a way that really displaces the
conversation about contemporary
discrimination all of which leads to the
point that one could definitely point to
the holes in the reservation program and
I think Pratap has has very eloquently
stated the ways in which it undermines
real conversation for reform
but when reservations have been the only
program that have found some traction in
terms of enforcement then isn't taking
that away a serious injustice and a
serious ethical quandary for the
contemporary forms of discrimination
that exists that have found no other
traction in Indian society today I'm
from India just a point to add Smitha
that a special component plan we are
talking about the Government of India
ensures 16.2 the empowerment of the
rates but never it's been fully utilized
only four to five percent has been
utilized for the development of our
empowerment of Dalits and nothing is
worked out so far about this this is one
point I would like to make and you are
talking about social mixing which we
hardly find it in institutions as well
as in the society and media meals
program the dominant caste
consciously keep away the children their
children out of the school from eating
along with adult children or the food
cooked by the Dalits so where where you
know this is not the fault of the then
it's like they are utilizing the
policies of the government for social
mixing but you know it's consciously
kept or awaited by the attitude mindset
of the dominant caste this is the one
point
this is regarding Methos statement that
ethical relationship rising out of
reservation policy there may be
different perspective from the point of
view of the Dalits as long as the OBC
gets reservation they are safe and
secure because their desolation will not
be taken away otherwise every other day
you'd find the newspaper that the
reservation policy is going to be banned
so the lists are put into a heart
pressure and they can always type at our
attention to some other activity
another thing you made a comparison with
the United States saying that
opportunities are given to students to
qualify themselves well it's alright
because the equal education is provided
and the opportunity given as justified
but compared India where are the schools
there are no equal schools so the
situation is different I want to mention
this thank you this is Raj family from
greater international mission
India has almost in the last two decades
have almost given up reservation
benefits for the Shoshone tribe as far
as the job reservations are concerned
with the shift from to the free market
economy it was anywhere never fulfilled
before but after 91 free market reforms
it is almost stopped so that's what we
are talking about and the caste
discrimination stays as as it is and now
the share rule Kushiro drives the Dalits
are facing much more problems in terms
of job requirements and India I this one
I want to highlight that Government of
India has almost stopped the reservation
in literal sense mr. Pratap neither
very brief assault I mean I think what
Paul which everybody all the questions
may be absolutely right which is which
is it is really about the reality of
integrity oppression there's no question
about it what are the instruments that
can deal with that I mean that's a
larger conversation we need to have
about you know what I don't want to say
I mean the one thing which I will resist
I think is is the is the political
judgment about that reservations would
be abolished if OB sees reservation was
attenuated I mean I think there's not
only no evidence for that but but but
but actually I mean I think I I do think
the one consensus there was an Indian
society whether it was enacted or not
was in a sense about the special history
of the others and and I've never bought
this political judgment that reservation
will be taken take you know they take it
away there's absolutely no no no no no
no evidence for it and in fact in fact I
think it is precisely that expansion of
reservation that has impeded us talking
about exactly these kinds of questions
that we need to be talking about in
order to keep the comparative focus here
I'm going to ask myself I'm going to ask
president Bollinger just to make a
comment about the contemporary and
relationship to professor novelist
question about about the about the
contemporary environment within which
these kinds of debates are taking place
and the historical as well as the almost
utopian character of this talk about
reparations and diversity tend to
obscure that in the u.s. we have now
three states California Washington and
Michigan that have had various state
ballots that have said that affirmative
action should no longer be used we have
growing a concern again obviously about
the importance of affirmative action at
the same time that the election of
President Obama has led many to say see
we don't need this anymore and in fact
many of the statements coming out of the
Obama administration
itself had been very ambivalent on the
question of affirmative action so I
wondered if Li if you could just say a
word about the contemporary today since
we know the same issues if in a very
different set of registers continue to
confront the african-american population
in the u.s. well so you you've
identified them and I I think that I
want to take the statement that you made
and agree with it that is in my
oversimplified sort of version of what
have been the inner tensions of
affirmative action in the United States
I want to say that the sort of effort to
link affirmative action and and what
it's doing what his purposes are what it
means is not only to when one says link
it to the historical roots it's also
linking it to the present and to the
discrimination that exists that is the
problems have not been overcome and that
is something that I think my own view
has been that is critical to maintaining
the social meaning of everything both
the historical roots and the recognition
of reality as it is so so I mean anybody
who thinks that racism is is gone in
American society is crazy
we just way too much
very painful evidence and and most of
the cities in the United States many of
them are more segregated today than they
were in 1955 1960 and even though it's
through housing patterns and and the
like there are so many public practices
that make that happen
contribute to that not least of which is
the system of school funding which bases
what kind of school you can go to on the
wealth of the people in your district so
there's so many practices that lead to a
that is truly fractured along racial
lines so you you want to keep that
reality before you and you want to keep
the the narrative of history present and
and that's what gives it energy and
that's what gives it meaning and and and
the like and yet there are very good Pro
affirmative action reasons as well as
anti ones for wanting to disconnect it
and that that's really my one of my key
points that it's it's got this inner
tension even when they're in favor of it
to want to disconnect it from from all
of this and I'm afraid we are and and
that from my point of view that happened
for such a long period of time that kind
of disconnected this that it allowed
people who were really against
affirmative action for other reasons to
really gain the upper hand in American
society and I think we are now so far
away from I mean just in terms of time
from 1954 and 1960 and 65
I think we're so far away new generation
detached from from these events and the
and the failure of the proa firm to
exercise to keep it the story alive has
led to a point in time when the firm
infraction has lost a huge amount of its
social meaning and I think that's really
unfortunate given the reality of present
discrimination and there is a lot of
movement to try to to as we know to try
to gain maintain this and also the
opponents that so the high ground is
let's start doing class rather than race
and that's the and the answer to that is
from my point of view of course we
should do class yes we do class actually
but don't fool yourselves doing classes
not working on race in America if you
only take account I've given the speech
hundred times the studies that have been
done by some people and our law faculty
if you have a system of admissions in
higher education and all you look at is
the income of the family that's all you
know just the sort of where they are in
the economic system you're going to get
a class that's overwhelmingly white
because the numbers end up that way so
so it's not a benefit and then and then
we know that the claim also that one of
the things that constantly undermines
affirmative action as a social policy is
the feeling that it's well it's based on
racial classifications we said that was
wrong now we're using it to sort of that
that's a conundrum that's a paradox so
it's that inner kind of tension that
constantly has to be explained and I
think that's where history and present
reality really matter again that that is
playing itself out here to again very
powerfully so when President Obama says
I do not believe my children should get
the benefits of affirmative action there
are many many people in the society who
take that to mean affirmative action has
run its course it's done its job it's
time to to move on and I think we're
that's where that 25-year period of
Sandra Day O'Connor is so significant I
think we're sort of in that most people
think we're in the twilight of what this
is all about when in fact the reality
continues in very very I'm gonna take
just a few more questions we have about
five minutes please make your comments
make your questions as sharp and as
crisp as possible
my name is Gangan Bundy before all the
questions go to Pratap I want to ask
another question of Lee Bollinger and
and one that has some comparative
interests I think you identify very well
distinction between talk about
historical injustice and the idea of
quality of education diversity right I
think the real challenge both in India
and in the United States must be to go
beyond what is politically acceptable to
to maintain what you call the social
meaning of affirmative action to
maintain that one needs to go beyond
what is socially acceptable that is
diversity in some sort of loose you know
liberal sense and to to bring to its
heart the question of historical and
contemporary injustice to maintain that
as part of the discourse so my question
to you really is this you said that you
wanted to matter to refer to both when
it came to cases in Michigan I wonder
how you actually do that and to get
Sandra Day O'Connor to hear that just as
in the Indian case there are particular
things that are here that you can
actually hear that are acceptable and
those are the arguments that people put
forward because they are the ones that
are effective well very quickly the the
data are fairly compelling and they go
like this most young people who arrive
on the campuses of our major
universities come from high schools that
are basically all black or all white so
the way I put it the first time they
encounter an integrated world in their
educational and in their leavin in their
lives is when they are on our campuses
now that can be an overstatement in some
universities versus others but it's a
basic truth about American society and
and it sort of Riaan
illuminates a point if you're especially
if you're in law because Brown versus
Board of Education was supposed to that
have stopped that from being the case
and here we are 50 plus years later and
and then you say there must be something
really really difficult about getting
the society to integrate across racial
ethnic lines so that must be something
really hard to do and it must be
something that's much goes much beyond
race and ethnicity to the ways in which
we think about groups and the ways in
which we think about other people and
we've identified as different from
ourselves and that turns out to be a
fairly profound subject of Education
whatever you're dealing with not just
race or ethnicity and therefore you have
a prime human experience that is
intimately related to everything we do
in most everything we do in in education
especially in the humanities social
sciences and professions and therefore
it is meaningful from educational
diversity standpoint but you have to
marry the two because if you just mean
diversity educational diversity which we
believe in but it has to be rooted in
some I mean to in practice it has to be
rooted in something that makes it
educationally valuable and what does it
here is how people perceive other groups
I have the I had the privilege here in
1991 to celebrated ktem but cuz birth
anniversary I thank the Columbia nursery
for all the wonderful programs that you
have been holding in that now our
organization has been going to United
Nations for the last 20 years in 1996 on
committee on elimination of racial
discrimination who brought the be issue
of discrimination and committee gave a
judgment that India should start
immediately on article 31 a human rights
education to educate the Indian
population on eradicating the
institutionalized thinking of high cost
and low cost mentality India has not
taken it seriously we had the meetings
with the National Human Rights
Commission also on that matter this is
part one part two is on the education
matters committee on child rights also
brought yes yes I the Committee on child
is also recommended the National
education for all the children according
to Indian Constitution that has not been
implemented
my question is India boasted the largest
and biggest democracy around the world
whereas it fails to implement even the
recommendations of a international body
how do we make the country like India to
abide by it
I think we're gonna ask each of our
panelists to just make a less comment if
they if they have one and you do of
course invoke one of the issues that
president Bollinger alluded to in his
opening remarks about the international
context within which now increasingly we
need to think about these questions but
also upon which we will need to what
upon which we'll need to rely in order
to make sure that actually things
continue to change in some fundamental
ways but mark do you want to just know I
just wanted to say that I think there
are many justifiable criticisms of the
Indian programs in terms of their
priorities and in particular
implementation but I do think we we sort
of step back a little we should
appreciate the the persistence and
generosity in in terms of of the Indian
programs in terms of institutionalizing
a kind of generosity at the national
level which is really quite rare with
all its shortcomings and and all its
faults it is I think a quite remarkable
achievement
and it also embodies that kind of you of
Indian civilization over the long haul
that I think is some protection against
the kind of very short run we must have
a the kind of short run perspective that
it seems to me is is definitely for so
many social programs
I think the full answer to your question
it will be should be the subject of
another conference at this Center in the
years time to take it it will take that
that much time but but the short answer
is you you you you have to you know
there are no quick fixes you have to do
the hard work of politics it's not
something legal scholars like to hear
it's not something activist like that is
the truth my last comment is just to say
that the question that was raised by all
of our panelists especially in reference
to India about the extension of
reservations from scheduled castes and
tribes to some backward classes or
castes and then Other Backward Classes
OB C's of course as you know and as
Pratap said feeds into or builds out of
rather an extensive history of political
mobilization and indeed going back to
the early 20th century but also raises
many very pressing contemporary
questions about the relationship between
reservations and popular popular
mobilization and and and and political
action but these two will require
another conference so I hope the
southern Asian Institute will reconvene
us for all sorts of questions soon but I
want to thank our panelists for a very
very stimulating
thank you everyone Thank You president
Bollinger for taking time out of your
schedule to come and do this thank you
for that mark and make